[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
GameSpot Krauss kind of funny as our big
old naughty blog uncharted rockbot keeps
happening this Troy Baker I love that
you like stuttered you what that's who
is that
who's this guy who is this your hair you
heard us all your hair you did this
Samson move you don't have strength I
mean it's it's weird I look at III like
the beginning of the year yeah it's so
like January it's like the Chinese New
Year for me because this is like when we
get to see everything for the first time
so there's like a freshness to it so III
decided to chop it it was at 43 it
wasn't for a roll no with what I do put
it in the helmet the but you should have
seen literally on the III had a talk
that I have a great friend who who cuts
my hair and she had to have a moment to
like bring herself to but it was like
below my shoulders yeah long as long you
on the floor was just like this it
looked like someone had just thrown the
carcasses of gerbils just no on the
floor this is great was there even like
with you wasn't just time did you it was
time it was time and and my little
brother foster get oh like foster giving
me like grief over it and so I wanted to
surprise everybody and that there was no
remorse there was like let's do this
let's do this this is how we're starting
the interview is by me talking about my
hair
he's Troy Baker what else do you expect
from him is it trending Troy's haircut
is trending so anyways fine let's talk
about Uncharted I okay so you we sit
back and we work on the game for for a
long time and you know we get to play it
out in our mind in whatever way it's
gonna look yeah the first time that I
got to see the demo finalized finished
was at the press conference and then I
was sitting right next to Laura Bailey
and never heard of her which she's a
she's a brilliant actress she she was
the belle of the ball she was in a lot
there was a lot I was like there we go
abdicated the throne he's coming for
your throne yeah she is man and she can
have it she's talented but we're sitting
there watching it and I do
III go back to me as a fanboy you know
five six years ago and being such a fan
of this franchise and never never would
have thought that I would be sitting in
that seat first of all every time I get
to go to the press conference or coming
to e3 or whatever I still feel like I'm
a fool somebody and that I've sometimes
nook in the back door and to be sitting
there watching that on that massive
screen and hearing the people's response
and seeing how good it looks to be in an
uncharted game is is like feather in the
cap it's amazing is it is it a different
vibe working on that game and doing the
mocap and stuff for it and you know
obviously capturing all the stuff the
same time then Last of Us yeah I mean
there's every game is intrinsically
gonna have its own DNA it's gonna feel
differently when you're making it and
uncharred it has its own voice it has
its own thing and that's you know the
Last of Us had that challenge making
sure that even though it was a naughty
dog game and wanted to feel like a
naughty dog game but not feel like
Uncharted sure with with two different
people walking around so going back to
uncharted this first time I've ever been
on a set of uncharted yeah but it's fun
to see you know Nolan riff and and all
the things you think about as a fan to
see oh this actually does happen he and
some mean things but yeah in this to me
one of the challenges of doing a
franchise is making sure that you're not
just rehashing and going now we're going
here right it feels like a different
experience and I think that from from
the top down from what Neil and Bruce
the game that they're creating Josh the
game that he's writing and letting this
feel like it's the culmination of
something that fans have been with for
almost ten years you know and making
this feel like a payoff to some of the
other things there's things to me that
that as a fan I look and I see we're
paying off from one from two from three
and and making this feel like a
different experience and that you as
fans have grown with this franchise the
characters have grown through the
franchise it's a different Nate Drake
it's a different Sully you got this new
character Sam that comes into kind of
like you know shakes up the mix a little
bit the relationship between Nate and
anna-lena is a little bit different so
if it'll be different in a good way
if it's the breakaway all right good
all right I love that Elena does it
serve the function of a romantic
interest that she's actually she has
agency in this story yeah and that was
even from the onset of one like you know
she starts out being this
photojournalist face in the woods she
grabs him and punches him that that's
good so now what I have sources okay at
Naughty Dog okay so they made a big deal
about how this isn't this wasn't
captured exactly the same as of course
last of us okay
you had new mocap suits that I guess
helps you do all this different stuff
out there something like I had I'm
looking at these things here these are
someone that was prepping for the role
you know obviously we take place in a
pirate the pirate story it was just a
weird mix up of putting a pirate Sam
Drake is something with future look at
that now that's actually that's actually
Greg Cipes okay no that's that's me
don't I look like a hobbit I look super
short in this picture for some reason
you look like the terrifying broke-ass
ships how did I not notice that that
many pictures were being taken that one
I remember it I was like guys don't take
this picture
that's literally what I'm saying and I
have this weird like Abbey Road walk I'm
not John I'm not Paul I'm neither of
them but yeah this this one almost looks
super epic except for the Frappuccino
you think about it for the Frappuccino
and their guard Eddowes this is that I
feel like you know California generally
is weird enough where you could just be
a normal gentleman going to get some
Doritos in the store and then about your
business you're now who's there your we
went to every year we go to the rent
fair it's it's one of our favorite
holidays to go to but we didn't stop
there there's a there's a place called
oubliettes which in French means place
of forgetting and you say I'll have a
mutters milk and they say okay mutters
milk and they give you a pint of ale and
they say hands behind your back don't
stop chugging till I stop pouring and
they grab like raspberry Mead and they
start pouring it it's a frat party and
you have to chug chug chug chug chug we
did that three times that's not good and
I literally don't remember past that
last time
apparently we went to a restaurant that
we frequent quite often in full garb in
full regalia okay with no apologies
unabashedly character the whole time Oh
me you think you can only call your
server a wench once before managed
becomes a conversation with me yeah
we're we're glad you guys are having fun
yeah thanks so much you need to leave
yeah we do not validate your parking
hope you enjoyed your steak fries now
I'm gonna say you know we can talk about
on chard and we can about Renaissance
Fairs that's all well and that's all
good but that jacket this jackets
fantastically print on it
that's a jacket I I stole this from a
homeless person who is very sharply
dressed yes thank you I love you too so
cool now this shirt is reflective by the
way it says it this is reflective very
so I can go running or just be seen I
can't be incognito in this shirt we're
not all gems troit or so you you know
uncharted next year you have a game
that's very it that's imminent
yeah it's imminent Batman of course yes
yes are you excited for everyone to
finally get their hands on this bad boy
yeah and what I love about that game is
you know it they're finally lauding it
as you know the the epic combination of
that franchise as well and and I was
super surprised at the Sony presser the
intro that they showed to that that was
my tweet of like oh you haven't finished
Arkham City [ __ ] you you're out of time
this is how it ends but even I mean
starting off first person that way going
in with the great vo from-from Gordon to
me really sets totally what that game is
it's always been a dark game yeah but
that was like really dark we're going
back to even darker than what like the
Scarecrow missions were in the original
asylum and it still takes me back like I
read Arkham Asylum the graphic novel
years and years ago and when I found out
they were making the game I didn't know
how they were gonna take that graphic
novel like all the graphic novels why
would you take that one and try to turn
it into a game and the way that they've
iterated upon that first of all shows
the strength of the Batman franchise
that you know and only over 75 years of
history but to be able
take something like that and be able to
embellish upon it and incorporate all
different elements into it and then
create your own narrative and your own
version of those characters you do that
and have that be so prolific really says
a lot about Rock City and and and again
the Batman franchise I'm super thrilled
that I got to come back because I got to
face as a fluke I was originally coming
in to do some some one-off characters
and and I got to do Nightwing and then
they said hey do you think you can do
this and Richard ball was like my that's
as Mark Hamill is my Joker Richard Maul
is is my two-faced because I think he
just did such a great job with the
animated series so to be able to kind of
emulate that yeah and this and this
franchise was huge but I foster Knight
and Travis both are just saying that's
pretty much gonna take over our lives
next week it's it's oh yeah it's been a
long time coming
and what's great is that we're at this
point where everyone you know pissed and
moaned because all these games were
being delayed but now they're here shut
up and just play it and enjoy it and
realize it was all worth it yeah it's
nice that the games are finally finally
getting here yeah absolutely when I'm
most curious about with you Troy because
like you're you're so talented and and
you you find you find these you know it
just seems like you identify great games
in their embryonic state in order to
attach yourself to these projects
because I'm sure people are knocking
down your door or don't like that you
want these game add a few misses there's
been a few this is gonna be the greatest
game ever I didn't know it's not the
bargain been two weeks I hear it comes
up but how do you find at least these
last few years like are people like
knocking down your door to get attached
to these games how do you identify what
games you want to be part of them what
games you don't want to be bar okay I
anytime as an actor anytime you get a
job that's a win you're in an industry
that 90% of its workforce is unemployed
so it's never lost to me anytime someone
says yes we want you that's that's it
that's a huge win the greatest
compliment that that an actor can be
given I think is to be thought of as a
solution to a problem and it's like with
uncharted neil calling me up is like i
gotta pull you in can you do this i need
someone that understands the franchise
that we know we can work with that it
has a relationship with nolan that
basically has that banter already back
and forth and that to me more than
anything more than like awards or
or even money or anything else is is for
someone who you respect to look at you
and go you can solve our problem and so
yeah it becomes this minefield to get
the tap-dance around because like last
year we had no control over when all of
these games were gonna come out every
game that I was in slipped and they just
happen to come out at the same time it
was like within months of each other and
for like a someone who's in film or
whatever that would be death you become
the Nic Cage and that's the one thing I
didn't want to become in in games so
yeah you start kind of parsing out going
okay this this is kind of similar to
something I've done before what what it
won't be really be a challenge if it's
not a challenge for me I want you to
find someone that it is a challenge for
because they will inherently do a better
job so we start crafting opportunities
and we start having conversations and
you know eventually this this train is
gonna pull into the last stop and it's
it's people gonna get sick of me no no
it's totally fine it's just the I'm a
prizefighter that's the way that I look
at it and I remember Sugar Shane Mosley
was my favorite boxer and I remember his
first fight and I remember his last
fight and there were six years apart so
that's not a long time but what he
accomplished in that time he set records
you know and and that's all you can hope
to do is get in the ring and take
punches and knockouts and that's that's
what you want to focus on and then
eventually trying to start parlaying
that in other things and I'd love to you
know position myself to to stay working
inside a games but maybe in a different
capacity maybe in a different role maybe
looking at into producing maybe looking
in a directory I don't know I just want
to say working in this industry because
I believe in and I believe that games
are the evolution of the narrative and I
believe that people want experiences
they just don't want to be entertained
I like that prizefighter metaphor us I
wanted to tell you some news at five
year I'm going to be talking like did a
fantastic answer totally marred by
travis willingham get up here travis no
no no no now you did it
now you guys ladies and gentlemen please
welcome to the stage travis with my best
friend and nemesis what are they oh [ __ ]
me almighty Doug let me try this really
haven't I need a mic up here hold on
we're getting you my right now
Travis asked if I if I represent some
ones probably fire
I like into my career to that of a
prizefighter meaning they're going on
your huge noggin hold on meaning you
take a lot of hits now angle that guide
towards about there you go yeah whatever
you try to stand always camera-ready for
as long as you can it takes it takes a
team around you you got to have your cut
man you gotta have your train I really
like we need fan art of you as a
prizefighter though I mean I want to see
like wrapped knuckles I want to see
gentlemen you know you know what even
bruised tweet at kind of funny vids and
at Troy Baker VA I do not doubt that
literally within 30 seconds it's like at
the New York Comic Con somebody within
60 seconds of me doing that Joker
monologue already had the coolest
picture of me up oh yeah that having me
half Joe tonight and as she was like I
don't know man with the new hair we
could get like some Muay Thai fighter
thing going on oh yes some ribbon but I
want I want like if it's like UFC I want
like round three end of that last round
like like beaten like trying to look
like like Tom Hardy and warrior like
beaten up that if you're gonna do this
Photoshop this to your face that would
be amazing
Travis's head is proportionate to his
body because its massive it is my head
I'm Travis his body would look like oh
are you born in the eighth month says
you would look like what the as if the
morning-after pill kind of worked in
going by here you're talking about the
Renaissance fear do you see the pictures
did the picture go up we called him the
spice merchant yeah right because then
all of the blue and the light blue like
he was literally the most exotic spice
merchant and the thing is um Sonic
you only have one outfit right yeah the
same old answer okay here's how
happens we ingratiate we're taking up
everybody's time
I haven't feel like shoes time is just
getting completely wiped off we'll talk
about nothing forever we bring you into
the Renaissance Fair you must dress in
normal clothes look at that Greg Cipes
is it I mean yeah yeah but you can
razors on there's a little ecig action
you get your commemorative mug you walk
to the first pierced and because it's
11:00 a.m. and you need alcohol and you
start drinking that's the one that's the
ones the photo with the winds not going
through the hair we're cheating the
audience I mean really it is a beautiful
thing to hold there is someone with a
fan walking in front of me that's a
thing dude that's that's like a look
like a show dog it's amazing it's got a
lot so a lot of weird things that I
would walk into the convenience store to
get mad my gatorade whatever I'd see
that'd be like all right this
gentleman's just going about nobody gave
me a second look even the guy the
register was like no reaction whatsoever
now this is happening you're wearing for
your go back to talking about uncharted
all right we're just gonna look for
Bruce Straley like talk about the game
don't care okay now Travis who are you
in uncharted I've noticed that you guys
are a little close you're a traveling
traveling gang of voice actors if
what-have-you pops up the rest are there
somewhere you know we're just a
traveling gang of a gang a gang of
rogues voice actors I'm actually not in
uncharted you get to you get to
appreciate this one as a pure fan that's
right I do
I frequently tell Troy anything with
Naughty Dog I'm like don't do not
swallow wintergreen Lives neighbor and
it betrayed me
anything with Naughty Dog I'm like don't
tell me don't tell me I'm last of us
don't tell me Uncharted because I want
the story I don't want any kind of like
hidden peek into what happens and I know
other people that are also an uncharted
which I'm not allowed to say anything
about but I know nothing about your wife
yes no who's that who Laura Bailey Oh
woman in everything we saw the extended
demo though and I was telling Bruce and
Troy and me'll that whoever was playing
that demo over and over again has the
hardest job in the world that demo
looked so insanely hard to play and I
know they've probably done it a thousand
times but he was headshotting people
while hanging from the crane being
dragged through the mud when the thing
flips over up can we also just throw out
some extra love for one Bruce Straley
yeah and how I didn't see anybody else
and if I'm wrong there was no man's sky
that they played live but I don't think
anybody else did alive gameplay gameplay
demo at at the presser Foster and Bruce
Bruce has had the game break on him he
is he has died he joined the Bruce
because the cord was too long and that
man got so much love because there was
nothing better than when they open it I
was like alright let's go and they just
stands there in that idle pose and he
couldn't get it to work and they had to
restart it and then like 10,000 people
of course it was great and that again I
think that just shows that that Naughty
Dog makes games for gamers they make
games that that ingratiate their fans to
them because you can tell that they're
gamers that are making games but I I
gotta say Bruce never stopped doing live
demos because they are infinitely more
entertaining than anybody else that's
true
sorry waters in Nick's doing stuff Tim's
out there and I hear Ashley Johnson's in
the crowd now there's - Lee juck
traveling voice actor oh yeah those
stars any second Laura Bailey's gonna
come over the side of the wall you don't
want to know about Naughty Dog games
right popping up in Naughty Dog games
what makes Naughty Dog special that you
guys go the store I mean it's the story
telling me I mean it's it's literally
the combination of gameplay Steward
gameplay supporting the story I mean for
me the two the two demos for me were the
Tomb Raider the Tomb Raider trailer and
uncharted 4 yeah it just they never
cease to
amazed me with the environments the
scenarios the walking through the crowd
in the in the trailer alone and then
it's breaking into chaos and then all of
a sudden you've left that area that the
trailer starts in and you've moved all
the way down the side of that hill now
you're going through ravines along the
side of the bridge or your honor you're
on a crane if you see the extended
trailer it moves even further into other
environments like I just start to wonder
compared to other games that I played I
wonder if other you know other
developers are going like okay well
there goes the bar this is really
impressive again I think it's a top-down
philosophy that says Naughty Dog says we
want to make a game that we want to play
and that's they're constantly asking
themselves that question all the way
through and this demo didn't just go oh
this is the demo we're gonna do and they
made it there were several hard choices
that they made and things that we're
gonna be really really cool yeah that
they decided to cut and they I hope I'm
not telling tales out of school but
there was one thing that they could have
done just for the demo to really wow
people but then they would have had to
go back and deconstruct everything
because there's no way they could have
done it in the game and they decided to
not represent a game just for e3 that
they couldn't do that was actually gonna
be on the shelves for gamers and that's
a really really hard choice for a
developer to make totally so for them to
be able to do that shows that they want
to make a game that they're proud of
that they want to play that feels fun to
them that feels grounded that feels real
that they know they can hand to someone
and feel proud of and know that they're
not gonna disappoint and I think a lot
of people glossed over the fact that
when you're in the truck that wasn't
scripted like Bruce was choosing I'm
gonna go this way versus this way so as
opposed to people going oh well now we
can need to go open-world because that
will amaze people it's understanding
what people want out of a game giving
them elements of that but still keeping
it within the DNA of what they do what
they do well so have I mean I remember
watching through the the first iteration
of the demo going wait the first time
you went this way man are you with this
one exactly there's no yellow path
that's showing you have to go this way
and if you go this way you'll run into a
hedge or a fence that won't allow you to
do that there's multiple ways nuts being
able to do that and that to me blew my
mind somebody goes oh you don't have to
drive that fast either I was like
you mean you control the speed and the
direction that you're going and the
environment is totally destructible that
it just massive yeah it kills you huge
all the street yeah stop at the safe you
know that debris I'm aiming for the
sheds the debris wouldn't blows [ __ ] I
wanted the windshield to shows like this
and mainly for Troy since Travis is
unemployed I assume yeah totally for you
Troy how hard is it to come to shows
like this and talk about a game like
Uncharted but not tip your hand to what
you know or what's happening this is
part of the job
yeah worst part of the job is that you
get to make you get to be a part of
making something so cool that nobody can
know about and we've seen kind of that
that embargo start moving moving closer
and closer up to or further away from
the date start letting some information
slide because people get more savvy it's
almost impossible to control all
information it used to be I remember her
final fantasy I wasn't allowed to
announce that I was playing snow until I
walked out on stage at their launch and
said by the way this is why I'm even
here so you know I think that there's
more of a partnership mentality between
the actors and the team to understand
that we can really help proliferate this
game because there's a lot of noise
there's a lot of games that are coming
out and in these ambassadors to speak up
and talk about it
so we're happy to be in that position to
be able to speak intelligently about
games so they bring us in to understand
what it is that we're making so we're
not just focusing on this one partner
but being able to have actual talking
points that that we're excited about
but yeah it's super hard to to come here
and and not go oh I want you to see this
one specific thing that's what can't you
even say about Sam right like he's his
brother and he's his brother
they've been estranged for for some time
and to me that we've talked about this
it's his older brother and I'm glad
you're sitting here yeah yeah there's so
many things that that Travis and I
workshop together with because there's
there's things that the jobs that he'll
be on that he's like hey help me out
with this or I'm the same ways like help
me out with this because we understand
how each other works yeah I understand
each has pit Falls and he and I I'm old
than him but in so many ways he's the
older brother I was gonna say he looks
like [ __ ] though but you but it's it's
understanding that age does not
necessarily mean elder right right right
and you know he's got a younger brother
that he has to be the older brother for
and so that I do a lot of stupid stuff
and so he's always there to kind of like
bring me into you know bring me back to
Center and that to me is the
relationship that that Sam and Nate have
which is they were both stuck in this
one time and they both needed each other
for this one thing but now Nate's kind
of moved on from that and he's found his
family in Sully and Elena he's been able
to move on I don't think Sam ever has so
in some ways Sam is actually younger
than Nate so the elder becomes a young
and the younger becomes the elder and
that to me is the source of that
contention between the two of them so
you know like when like when he and his
younger brother Carson you know he used
to always be able to beat him up but
that Carson got big grew up first time
first time he was like shoved him and
Carson shoved him back it's like there's
there's like heads going through walls
and stuff so I'm really excited for
people to see that dynamic because we've
seen kind of the the the conflict
between Nate and and Sully we've seen
the conflict between Nate and Alaina and
all you see all the other characters you
got through there this is a new addition
to that they got it is something new and
fresh to it that I'm excited for people
to see I can't wait
uncharted 4 yep 26 2016 whatever Travis
is working on someday you want to keep
anything just your Twitter Tetris -
Tetris - it's about pretty reboot of
Tetris - yeah it's gonna be a our
augmented reality it's gonna be amazing
he plays the tea
thank you for watching GameSpot Krauss
kind of funny we're going nowhere we're
here all day long but right now Nick and
Alfredo are gonna tell you about a game
they saw or whatever the hell Nick talks
about
[Music]